- Keith and I are chefs, but not Korean.
- Right.
- Eugene is Korean, but not a chef.
So, how is that going to do?
- (splatter) Oh! (laughs)
- Zach!
(upbeat music)
- I think there is a growing
interest in Korean cuisine
because the popular culture introduced it
in such a delicious manner.
- What do you do?
- I am Hyosun Ro.
I am the Korean mom.
- You're the Korean mom
we've always wanted to have.
- Really?
- Family members eating around the table,
that's when many conflicts emerge.
- Keith and Ned had mom, so Eugene's going
to be my mom.
- I'm not going to be your mom.
- So, I got mom here helping me out--
- I am not your mom.
- Consumption of food is
not just something that
your body needs, but it's something that,
also, your emotion needs.
- Okay, today we're
going to make dukbokki.
- Dick pokey.
(Eugene laughs)
- Dukbokki is a number
one street food in Korea.
- Have you never had duck before?
- This is duck?
I've had duck before.
- It's not the bird
duck, it's a rice cake.
- That's a different kind of cake.
- It tastes like string cheese
that rolled under the couch.
So, mom, what's the first step?
- Not your mom.
- First thing we need to do
is to make anchovy broth.
- Anchovy broth.
- Are you freaked out by little fish?
- I'm not freaked out by it.
- Put the whole thing in your mouth.
(Zach mumbles)
There you go.
- Ned?
- Yeah?
- Do you want to do your job?
- Sure.
I didn't realize I had a job.
Whee, see, see?
- Just pour it in, Ned!
- Just pour it.
- (in singsong voice) One
more cup of fish water,
one more cup of fish water.
- Next thing we need to do is gochujang.
- That smells good.
- Gochujang?
- Gochujang, you've heard of it, right?
- I've seen it right
now, and it is very red.
- Am I going to regret
how much I put on this?
Is it real spicy?
- No, put on more.
- If I drank that whole thing,
would I be in the hospital?
- Stick that whole thing in your mouth.
- You [censored] me hard.
Oh my god, that was so spicy.
- Three tablespoons.
- (splatter) Oh!
- Zach!
- Eugene's a mean daddy. (laughs)
- You want to have extra spicy kick?
- No.
- Sure.
- Gochugaru.
- I don't trust you--
- Just put that whole thing in your mouth.
- Eugene, it's red.
- That's a spicy Tuesday.
- This is one tablespoon soy sauce.
- Go get it, bro.
- Garlic.
- Whee.
- Why do you have to try sugar?
- Mmm, this looks red.
- It's all about complexity and balance.
- All about balance.
- Wow, complexity and balance.
- I said balance at the same time as mom.
- Can I put my duck in there?
- You can put your duck in there.
- (singsong voice) All
the fingers in the pot,
fingers in the pot.
- I'm splishing splashing everywhere.
- Yeah, don't splash.
- This is called eomuk,
and it's fishy cake, and--
(Keith and Ned chuckle)
- It's like a flattened, fried
fish cake of sorts. - Cool.
- If you cut it diagonally...
- Yeah?
- it will be pretty.
- Ooh, go for it bro.
- Oh.
- Go for it.
- Little triangles, is that impressive?
- I love triangles.
- I'd chop the rest of this up.
- Okay. Oh no! (laughs)
Should I throw it?
- No, you're not throwing the fish cake.
- It seems like a fun thing to throw.
(laughs)
- I love cabbage.
- And what do I do with that?
Just chop it up?
- [Ned] Nice knife skills, Keith.
- [Keith] Thanks.
- So, can we put in the cabbage yet?
- Sure.
- Great! Go for it, Ned.
Just grab a fistful.
So, once you've got everything boiled
in for a second, then
you add these fish cakes.
- Now we just let this simmer for awhile.
- Dude, we're a great team.
There is no flaws in our system,
we worked really well together--
- No fish cakes were lost.
- Sesame oil is very important.
- Oh, can I taste some?
- It's going to taste like oil.
- Oh my god, that's delicious.
It's probably good for the skin, too.
- All right.
- Oh no, oh no!
- Ned, no.
- They say it's good for the skin.
- Ned, you said that.
Ned, no! Mom!
Ned, let me stand near the table. No!
- So it's now time to put
our final ingredients.
- Oh, we can all do it together.
- Sprinkle some scallions.
- Yay.
- Yes.
- Sprinkle.
- Oh no, it was all in one spot.
- That was a group [censored] up.
- You're not a part of this family.
- Nice, time for tasting.
- Okay.
- Mmm.
- Oh my goodness.
- It's good but it's spicy as [censored].
- It's so well balanced.
- We're all having a Korean good time.
- You good, Keith?
- Yeah, I'm good.
(Zach laughs)
- You need water?
- Probably.
- Could we get water?
- I don't know.
- Alright mom, what's our next dish?
- So, we're about to cook one of my
favorite childhood Korean dishes.
- Mhmm. Korean kimbap
is very well seasoned.
It's very easy to make.
It only takes three ingredients inside.
Because we're making mini kimbap,
we're going to cut this in half.
- What's over there?
- Eugene!
- Oh my gosh, to my
core I just got chills.
That's the way my mom says "Eugene!",
and she'd get the rice scooper.
She would just be like
(makes slapping sounds).
- Oh, no, no! (laughs)
- You have to season this really well
for kimbap to taste good.
We're ready to roll.
Lift the end that's closer
to you, and just roll it.
There's no really magic to it.
- The other Try Guys have
to do this on their own,
and they're going to compete to see
who can make the best mini kimbap.
I think Keith's will taste the best.
I think Ned's will look the best.
- Ned all the way.
- What are you sawing?
- I think Zach's going to be the one
that's just going to be an
explosion of rice and stuff.
- Okay, so we each have
two minutes to make kimbap.
- If you've been watching this video,
you probably expect me
to do horribly on this.
I'm going to try and prove you wrong.
- First, rice, already seasoned.
I've got a nice bed of rice.
- You don't need that much rice.
- Take your time.
Patience is important when cooking.
- How many of these did she put in?
Two.
I hope it was two.
- He was wrong, you only
need one of these things.
- I rolled things in college, so I have
prior knowledge on how to do this.
- I think I might have
put too much rice in here.
- And you roll it, and
you're [censored] done.
This is not that hard.
- Oh no, I'm losing time.
So hard to recover once
you've [censored] it up.
- Lube this up.
- Sprinkle dinkle.
- This is real slippery.
- Let's make another.
I'm not feeding my only
one I made, Eugene.
[Censored] Eugene.
(laughs)
(long beep)
- Yes!
- So now we're going to
judge the other Try Guys'
kimbap to see which one is the best.
- This one is not the best.
- It's a very, like, (muffled)
person in a very small shirt.
- Yeah.
- What about the sesame on each one?
- I think this was a little bit overdone.
- Looks like there's a lot of seeds.
But the extras on the sides here
is very Korean, actually.
- It's very Korean, right.
- You should probably eat it
just to be sure which
one tastes good, right?
- So your official decision is?
- The middle one.
(Zach yells)
- Number two!
- My name is Keith, and I
know how to cook, y'all.
- Who is second best?
- This one, yeah.
- Who is--
- Yeah, I'm the second best
Korean cook of all time, yay.
- This carrot sticking out
is a feature, not a bug, huh?
- No, we Koreans like it.
- We've all learned something today.
- (in unison) Cheers and
thanks to our Korean mom.
- Thank you, you're welcome.
Thank you, I love you too.
Korean food is not that hard to make.
It's very approachable.
Select a dish, find a
good recipe, and try it.
The more you practice, the better you get.
- (in unison) Try Mom.